[Music]
the site of mistletoe may either send
you scurrying or if you have your eye on
someone awaiting an opportunity beneath
its snow-white berries but how did the
festive Christmas tradition of kissing
under mistletoe come about the
long-lived custom intertwines the
mythology and biology of this intriguing
plant there are more than 1,000 species
of mistletoe which grows the world over
in fact the ancient Europeans were so
captivated by the plant's unusual growth
habits that they included it in their
legends and myths in ancient Rome Pliny
the Elder described how the druid
priesthood in ancient England believed
that mistletoe was a plant dropped down
from heaven by the gods that explained
it's unlikely position amongst the high
branches of certain trees they also
believed it had powers of healing and
bestowing fertility meanwhile
scandinavian legend holds mystical
qualities in the story of the god Baldur
and his adoring mother
Frigga goddess of love marriage and
fertility
Frigga loved her son so much that she
commanded every plant animal and
inanimate object to vow
they'd never harm him in her fervour
however she overlooked the mistletoe the
mischievous god Loki realized this
oversight and pierced Baldur's heart
with an arrow carved from a mistletoe
branch
Frigga cried tears of such sadness that
they formed the mistletoes pearly
berries making the other gods pity her
and agree to resurrect maldor hearing
the news
Frigga became so overjoyed that she
transformed the mistletoe from a symbol
of death into one of peace and love she
mandated a one-day truce for all fights
and that everyone embraced beneath its
branches when they passed to spread more
love into the world in the 17th century
British colonists arriving in the new
world found a different but very
similar-looking species of mistletoe
they applied it to these tales of magic
fertility and love spreading the
mistletoe hanging tradition from Europe
into America by the 18th century people
in Britain had turned this into a
Christmas tradition but this custom
comes down to more than just human
imagination all of it was inspired by
the plants intriguing biology we see
mistletoe as a festive decoration but
draped on tree boughs in the wild it's
known as a partly parasitic plant
mistletoe relies on modified roots
called historia that penetrate the tree
bark and siphon off the water and
minerals trees carry up their trunks to
colonize nearby trees with its seeds
mistletoe depends on birds and other
creatures to do the dispersing birds
that eat the mistletoes sticky white
berries sometimes get fit of the gluey
seeds by wiping them off onto tree bark
or with a bit of luck they excrete the
in de Geste Abul seed onto a treat
where it germinates and starts to grow
with its resilience and foliage that
stays lush even while the surrounding
trees lose their leaves you can see why
mistletoe captivated our superstitious
ancestors they saw these as signs of the
plants magical qualities and fertility
even today the mistletoe inspires wonder
with a diversity of wildlife it supports
more than just a parasite it's also
known as a keystone species it's eaten
by a diversity of animals including deer
elk squirrels chipmunks porcupines
robins bluebirds mourning doves and the
butterfly genus Delius some mistletoe
species produce dense bushes which are
excellent nesting locations for a
variety of birds and despite their
parasitic relationship with trees
mistletoes can also help other plants
for instance juniper sprouts in your
mistletoe to benefit from the visiting
berry eating birds through the many
benefits it provides mistletoe
influences diversity and allows
ecosystems to flourish you might even
say that for this iconic plant life
imitates legend in the wild mistletoe
has the power to bring things to
together and in our own traditions we
see that happening too
[Music]